when I was named President I was very surprised
to receive letters from young girls all over
the world and from parents and young girls
on all of the world
talking about how much it meant to them that
the President was a woman
mm-hm
this
feel they can do anything that the world was
open to them in a way they had wanted to be
before they've learned about my appointment
so when I went to China I went to visit and
girls' school in shanghai
and the young girls were intrigued as was
I with them
interested and women's roles interested in
how they could pursue their own dreams
0:01:19.180,0:01:21.210
and he same way
yes
he said he for important okay
uh-huh
it would be important to try to continue with
this effort to reach out to young women
across the world when I did travel
I mean it is an incredible opportunity being actually addressed by the president of Harvard
and that it actually opens your eyes that she's female
and it shows how human she is
and how down to earth
and then you realize
this is what you actually need
and this is crucial to the school in south
Africa
what you guys are doing is incredible
and I think we realized that
it makes anything seems possible
It was highly appreciated
and I guess I'm kind of had a sense of
an obligation to
fill that role
if it could be important to young girls
if it could be a motivation to
uh be ambitious about education and be ambitious
about the possibilities that I should use
my presidential status to follow up on that
I learned that
if you want something then you should go for it
the possibility of reaching Harvard is actually reality now instead of a just a very good dream
So I have actually learned a lot